buongiorno a tutti mi presento sono
simona fiorentini e sono la responsabile
marketing della fiorentina alimentari
spa io sono una persona normalissima
figlia moglie mamma lavoratrice porto
avanti l'attività della mia famiglia e
siamo arrivati alla quarta generazione
non so se sapete quello che si dice
delle aziende di famiglia
la prima generazione costruisce la
seconda consolida la terza distrugge
noi siamo arrivati alla quarta e adesso
tocca a me ea mia sorella fabrizia
nei vari passaggi generazionali di fatto
siamo state le prime donne a portare il
cognome ea operare in prima linea
una bella responsabilità
ma prima di noi ci sono state altre
donne che pur portando un altro cognome
o nelle retrovie hanno fortemente
indirizzato l'attività della nostra
azienda come mia nonna maria
mia nonna maria lavorava al bancone del
negozio di mio nonno accoglieva e
serviva i clienti aveva sempre una
parola gentile
e dolce per tutti e faceva sacrifici a
non finire infatti viveva nel
retrobottega del negozio e li ha fatto
crescere mio padre
col tempo poi è riuscita a mettere da
parte un po di soldini per acquistare un
alloggio nello stesso stabile del
negozio ma non un alloggio grande al
primo piano quello era per le persone
nobili per le persone importanti
no un piccolo bilocale al terzo piano
però che soddisfazione salire le scale
tutte le sere dopo aver finito di
lavorare e poi c'è stata la mia mamma
adriana mia mamma ha convinto mio padre
a portare avanti l'attività di famiglia
sì perché i miei nonni volevano che mio
padre avesse
un lavoro fisso uno stipendio stabile
che entrasse in banca mia mamma invece
lo convinse a diventare un imprenditore
anzi lei all'epoca lavorava in fiat e si
licenziò lasciò il posto fisso per
aiutarlo costruire il suo sogno senza di
lei oggi nessuno ci conoscerebbe infatti
è stata lei a prima la prima a credere
nel cognome di suo marito tanto da farne
un marchio di fabbrica disegno lei il
primo logo e anche le prime confezioni
dei nostri prodotti
in qualche modo possiamo dire che la
componente femminile della nostra
famiglia fortemente indirizzato
l'attività della nostra azienda
per quanto riguarda me io sono cresciuta
insieme a mia sorella fabrizia e alla
nostra terza sorella l'azienda sì perché
per i miei genitori
l'azienda è sempre stata come un terzo
figlio
o forse potrei addirittura dire come il
primo perché è stata concepita prima che
noi nascessimo
quando eravamo piccole i miei genitori
ci portavano spesso in azienda ci
facevano fare un po di tutto
inverno mettevamo posso l'archivio ve
state a volte l'avevamo le macchine nel
parcheggio in vacanza con i miei
genitori ho girato il mondo e ho anche
visitato tutti i supermercati del mondo
sempre alla ricerca di qualche
particolarità di qualche specialità
alimentare da importare nel nostro paese
vivere con persone estremamente in gamba
spesso non è facile
ti fa sentire inadeguata ma ti sprona
anche a fare sempre meglio per cercare
di essere alla loro altezza io mi sono
laureata nel 2004 a torino in economia e
poco dopo ho iniziato a lavorare in
azienda
non so dire se ho fatto bene o male sarà
il tempo a dirmelo però da subito mi
sono appassionata di vendite anche in
questo caso non so dire perché
probabilmente perché mi piaceva il
contatto con il consumatore è così da
subito ho iniziato a fare la gavetta
facevo da portaborse a mio papà e al
nostro direttore commerciale e con loro
abbiamo girato l'italia
da nord a sud visitando tutti i nostri
clienti dal piccolo dettagliante fino al
buyer della grande distribuzione
era un mondo molto maschile io mi
ricordo un sacco di appuntamenti dove si
passavano decine e decine di minuti a
parlare di aneddoti calcistici o di che
cosa aveva fatto la propria squadra del
cuore nei giorni precedenti e io non
capivo assolutamente nulla e mi sentivo
un pesce fuor d'acqua
e allora stavo zitta ascoltavo e cercavo
di imparare mi sono fatto un'idea di
quello che poteva essere il nostro
mercato è anche di che cosa potesse
volere il nostro consumatore che cosa
pensa che cosa desidera il nostro
consumatore cosa si aspetta da noi le
persone perché al centro di ogni
decisione ci sono sempre le persone e
tutti i giorni mi domando come posso
restare in contatto con le persone
come posso soddisfare le loro esigenze
in un certo senso era più facile per il
mio bisnonno perché con la sua bottega
riusciva a essere sempre in contatto
quelle persone ea chiacchierare con loro
anche solo semplicemente
mentre diventando grandi si perde
progressivamente questo contatto diretto
rapporto diretto che aveva ad esempio il
mio bisnonno perché ci troviamo sempre
davanti il filtro della grande
distribuzione
tutti i giorni ci troviamo a discutere
con i buyer per convincerli della bontà
dei nostri prodotti che hanno senso
trattarli sui loro scaffali non sempre
ci riusciamo
la cosa più difficile oggi per noi è
parlare di innovazione
sì perché nel nostro mercato di
riferimento quello dei prodotti
salutistici spesso siamo stati pionieri
e quindi abbiamo proposto spesso
prodotti che non esistevano e questo
credetemi è molto difficile perché
quando si va a proporre un prodotto
nuovo magari bayern ti chiede portami
dei dati di mercato supporto e noi non
li abbiamo perché si tratta di una
novità assoluta per il mercato e quindi
spesso e volentieri
torniamo a casa con dei sonori no e
questo è un po avvilente perché dopo che
hai passato mesi a pensare un prodotto
fare le prove mi gli assaggi e 6
fortemente convinto che questa possa
soddisfare le esigenze del consumatore
finale e poi ti trovi davanti un muro di
gomma non è proprio il massimo e quindi
spesso siamo un po afflitti ma
nonostante tutto se ci crediamo
veramente non molliamo
spesso mi chiedono come sia possibile
che la nostra attività sia durata così
tanti anni oltre cento e io dico che
probabilmente la nostra attività è
durata perché ha saputo cambiare pelle
adattandosi alle nuove esigenze del
mercato anche in base al carattere di
chi in quel momento la guidava il mio
bisnonno aperto il negozio di specialità
alimentari
mio nonno ha iniziato a importare
prodotti dall'estero mio papà gli ha
fatto fare il salto industriale e a me
ea mia sorella toccherà esportarla e
renderla digitale voi direte beh è
facile per te sei la figlia del capo ma
credetemi essere la figlia di non è
sempre facile prima di tutto perché ti
paragonerei sempre al top poi ti
sentirai sempre dire alle spalle ma lei
non è come loro
e vero non sono come loro e non so
ancora neanche quali risultati otterrò
però questo non vuol dire che non mi
impegni o che non lotti per quello in
cui credo ad esempio vi raccolto qualche
passaggio di scontro generazionale di
quanto dovuto lottare per cambiare tutte
le confezioni dei nostri prodotti sì
perché le nostre confezioni erano uguali
nostro logo era stato disegnato da mia
mamma ed era uguale negli ultimi 40 anni
e quindi i miei genitori assolutamente
non volevano cambiarlo ma io sentivo che
avessimo bisogno di modernità quindi
negli ultimi due anni abbiamo cambiato
tutto logo confezioni foto però con un
ritorno al passato abbiamo inserito
all'interno del nostro logo la data il
luogo della nostra fondazione torino
1918 e abbiamo anche inserito la nostra
storia per far capire al nostro
consumatore che siamo una famiglia
orgogliosamente italiana perché da oltre
100 anni cerchiamo di fare prodotti
buoni e e questa volta le confezioni le
abbiamo firmati a mia sorella il
risultato è stato incoraggiante perché
ci ha permesso di farci conoscere
maggiormente dal nostro consumatore che
ci apprezza e finalmente ci può
scegliere in modo più consapevole
non pensate che sia facile fare tutte
queste cose perché sono la figlia del
capo un altro grande scontro che ha
avuto con i miei genitori è stato dovuto
alle commerce
sì perché per me li commerce era un
sogno mentre i miei genitori non ci
credevano moltissimo per me era un po
come rimettere il nostro consumatore al
centro
voi direte com'è possibile che l'e
commerce metta le persone al centro sì
perché finalmente per noi riesce a farci
entrare con un contatto diretto con il
nostro consumatore che puoi trovare
tutti i nostri prodotti all'interno e
quindi può sceglier c in maniera più
consapevole
questa per me è stata una grande sfida e
ed è stato un po come ritornare alla
bottega del mio bisnonno
quindi ogni giorno in realtà io incasso
sono rino in azienda dai dai nostri
clienti dai nostri genitori da anche dai
collaboratori per ogni sera a rischio
tornare a casa col sorriso perché ad
aspettarmi ci sono i miei figli si sono
mamma di due bellissimi bambini vittorie
francesco che sono la mia ragione di
vita e ogni sera preparo la merenda per
loro è la metto nella cartella e questo
è un po mi fa sorridere anche mi aiuta
nel mio lavoro perché mi fa anche un po
capire quali sono le esigenze di altre
mamme papà ad esempio
a casa mi aspetta anche mio marito con
il quale condividono gioie e dolori del
nostro lavoro perché è il responsabile
del nostro stabilimento di produzione
che abbiamo costruito da zero negli
ultimi tre anni e che è stato costruito
seguendo un modello di edilizia
architettura sostenibile
questo perché teniamo moltissimo al
nostro territorio quindi abbiamo cercato
anche di armonizzarlo con tutto ciò che
ci circonda
abbiamo implementato un area verde molto
molto grande e piantato oltre 100 alberi
questo per renderlo gradevole non solo
per le persone che ci vivono e ci
lavorano all'interno ma anche tutte per
per tutte quelle che vivono intorno a
noi questo perché siamo legati
moltissimi a nostro territorio alle sue
origini e vogliamo cercare di
restituirli qualcosa per questo durante
l'anno della pandemia abbiamo effettuato
un'importante donazione è uno dei più
importanti ospedali di torino per
aiutarne nell'acquisto di alcuni
dispositivi di emergenza
nella lotta al cosib senza neanche
sapere poi che dopo qualche mese questi
stessi dispositivi ci avrebbero aiutato
a curare una persona della nostra
famiglia
e poi nello stesso modo sempre per
cercare di restituire qualcosa al nostro
territorio investiamo nella ricerca
scientifica in particolare sosteniamo un
ricercatore che opera nella nostra zona
a candiolo uno dei centri di eccellenza
e che studia per trovare delle cure
contro i tumori femminili
questo perché purtroppo questo brutto
male ha colpito duramente la nostra
famiglia una persona una donna molto
importante della nostra famiglia ha
perso la sua battaglia contro il tumore
al seno
un'altra grazie alla prevenzione ea curi
in centri specializzati è riuscita a
guarire e poi dipendenti collaboratrici
amiche la diffusione di questo male e
spaventosa e noi vogliamo essere vicino
a tutte le donne che ogni giorno
continuano a lottare
ecco questi sono per me i valori
veramente importanti però sarei un
ipocrita se dicessi che il fatturato
utile non sono altrettanto importanti
perché lo sono e anche perché ci
permettono ogni giovani delle lavoro a
centinaia di persone
ma siamo persone
restiamo persone e abbiamo bisogno di
altre per mi piace pensare all'azienda
come a una piccola comunità da
rispettare e proteggere
si dice spesso che dietro un grande uomo
ci sia una grande donna
ecco oggi che siamo qui a parlare del
ruolo della donna nella società
mi rendo conto che se siamo arrivati
dove siamo e grazie al lavoro enorme
delle donne della nostra famiglia che
con dedizione pur agendo nelle retrovie
hanno creduto fortemente in quello che
facevano e hanno intravisto un futuro
quindi oggi da donna a donna sono qui
per dire loro unicamente una cosa
grazie e grazie anche a tutti voi